[Music]
now some of you may think I'm
exaggerating when I say this November's
elections are more important than any I
can remember in my lifetime in this
election we are fighting to win and we
are going to win
Republicans and Democrats may genuinely
hate each other but they love their own
power even more that's why they collude
so often to keep those pesky
libertarians greens and independents
away from the lucrative levers of
government the 2018 midterms like all
campaign seasons have been shocked full
of two-party shenanigans all too often
aided and abetted by journalists
pollsters and the voters themselves it
all starts with ballot access if the
state government considers you a major
party getting on the ballot is a snap
worst case scenario you need to collect
signatures from a tiny fraction of your
own registered voter base best case you
just show up I knew it you're a major
party on third-party and independent
candidates on the other hand have to
collect tens of thousands of signatures
in some states 15,000 to run for
governor New York including at least 100
in each congressional district in fact
Arizona Republicans recently changed the
law to make libertarians have to collect
signatures not just from their own
voters but from registered independents
as well and by the way that doesn't
apply to the Green Party which means in
Arizona this year in the US Senate race
which is neck-and-neck
there's a green candidate but not a
libertarian some states push their
filing deadlines all the way back to a
year before the election that's one of
many reasons why candidates like Evan
McMullen when they get a sudden itch to
run for president are lucky to make it
on even a dozen balanced New Hampshire
this year herded all third parties under
the same ballot line confusingly titled
libertarians and other candidates New
Mexico tried and thankfully failed to
institute a straight party ballot
meaning voters in this 3-2 Democratic
state could automatically vote for all
the candidates in one party by checking
off just one box Gary Johnson's surging
poll numbers I am sure or purely
coincidental getting your name on the
ballot doesn't mean it's going to be
included in the polls
the Nevada race for US Senate for
example is universally rated a toss-up
and yet the first three independent
polls released this October did
not include libertarian Tim Hagan even
though previous surveys had him at
around 4% how about the debates
Pennsylvania Senate candidate Dale
Kearns was assured a spot on stage then
uninvited if we can implement fresh
ideas into the system they're going to
have to change Texas gubernatorial
candidate Mark Tippit's was told he
didn't have enough qualifying press in
part because his coverage in the
spanish-language media didn't count in
Texas all Texans have a right to hear
from all of the options that will be on
the ballot for governor this November I
have a governor candidate Jake Porter
who's polling higher than any other LP
Statehouse contender says his debate
invitations were rescinded in part
because he refused to buying commercials
the freer and more general the
competition Adam Smith wrote in 1776 the
more advantageous it will be to the
public
competitors he warned will always try to
widen the market and narrow the
competition our system of government
that other glorious achievement from
1776 has for too long been controlled by
the same type of market rigging forces
that Adam Smith warned us about it's
about time to make American politics
competitive again
[Music]